let me pull up this story it seems to be
it's just a weird story but it's a belly
of the beast man we got this story from
the daily mail ben and jerry's manager
is accused of dousing mentally ill
homeless person with a bucket of water
because she was crying on the sidewalk
outside of the store in san francisco
i don't even want to play the video um
it's just a crying homeless person
dude apparently comes out and splashes
water on them but there's there's so
much here obviously there's like a
culture uh canceled culture outrage
going on over this and people on social
media like how dare you but man does
this hit at the very serious problems of
cities like san francisco with
representation like nancy pelosi granted
she's at the federal level but still
this is her city she doesn't seem to
care about it
you've got the homeless crisis you have
the drug crisis you've got the failed
policies you've got human waste all over
the streets and then you've got people
saying that california is five years
ahead of the rest of the country
so you look at stories like this
and it's like this ben and jerry's
manager it's like a regular guy just ben
and jerry's like the ice cream yeah yeah
okay yeah the woke ice cream company the
ice cream company is right the extremely
politically correct woke ice cream
company what was what was it as long as
it's not homeless people what was that
really awful flavor they had it was woke
and had like a weird thing in it i can't
remember what it was i'll try to have
cinnamon in it no no what i love
cinnamon what are you talking about
i absolutely love cinnamon that's weird
you are so wrong i am i am offended that
someone cinnamon bun ice cream so good
to suck on a cinnamon stick before no
that's pretty good but
you ever do the cinnamon challenge you
guys ever do that take a scoop of
cinnamon and you put it in your mouth
don't i'm not suggesting you do it just
don't breathe out your nose yeah i think
it was shake carl talking about
what happens to a city when you don't
fight for it you lose it yeah and then
some i mean
would you describe san francisco as
being lost or maybe something worse
it's it's just it devolves into satanism
i lived there for a little while you
guys ever lived there i've been there
i've i've never lived there but i've
passed through for periods of time it
wasn't as bad when i was there this was
a long long time ago it was like 2015
for me and to be fair to like what
you're saying you have to keep fighting
because the uh i mean i hate to make
this a left person i think they're not
going to stop like i still get like i am
shocked by how many door-to-door
campaigners i would get in minnesota in
areas that were safe blue right uh and
the amount of messages you get from you
know this is so-and-so from this
campaign and you're like stop messaging
me and you're still going to keep
getting them and you're still going to
keep getting because they never stop so
if you're going to at least try to make
a change how can you just say oh well
this district is clearly blue why would
i even try they're going to try they're
going to go into those red districts and
they're going to keep trying whether
it's through the educational system
whether it's door-to-door campaigning
sending you messages they will not stop
it's cultural in every level so we can't
you know again i hate making this a left
versus right thing because i don't
consider myself a republican or democrat
or any of that but you can't stop this
okay
there you go say so yeah yeah so like
you you have to at least be willing to
fight for those what's the point you're
just giving in yeah no i mean and these
people aren't messing around they're not
kidding around i mean i i think the
whole three card monty manipulation is
whoever the voters are now let's guilt
them into voting democrat uh because
republicans are racist and and while
that takes place
we will we will use those wins to
systematically go into
uh the communities at the grassroots
educational school level and
indoctrinate the next generation so that
we won't even have to we won't even have
to lie anymore we don't even have to
manipulate them they'll believe the
things we believe the three-car monty is
like that game where you have three cups
with like a ball under it four cards or
whatever and so you're saying they're
using the the black community as like a
distraction and they're getting people
to look away so that they can move the
card the holocaust and adolf hitler are
the scapegoat and the justification for
new world order black people are the
justification for authoritarianism
authoritarian
church of lgbtq anti-human american
politics same game
just the same game
i got a question about this right that
they uh
some politicians recently said in the
past couple of years that the for
democrats the the the way to the black
voters through the church and and i've
you've heard that before right yeah i'm
live
but i'm wondering why why
50 sure i get what they're saying but
it's a lie but you constantly hear about
these democrats going to these black
churches to get votes or whatever and
they say that oh it's because the
churches have sway in the community and
then but now overblown i think right
right well tell me about that why why
where does that trick i think the
biggest i think the biggest um
two things one it's through pop culture
it's it's through the the subtle
um
very
uh underhanded presentation of a white
supremacy patriarchy
and that if you vote republican then
that is the patriarchy and so black
people are ju but it's also the
republicans don't feel the need to clear
that up right they haven't felt the need
to clear that story up and i get it i
mean if they
it's just not going to win the game i
was like morgan freeman he was like
don't call me a black man i'm not going
to call you a white man we're just men
yeah
i mean look here's the thing with the i
we can't we there's a very real
from a biology standpoint i i don't like
on the right when people say well look
race isn't even real like race is only
really okay go to a state penitentiary
and see how people group themselves out
of self-defense and preservation race is
real and people group themselves in
certain ways based on how they look and
like cultural values and there's nothing
wrong with that what's wrong is when you
give yourself the right to to violate
somebody else's natural god-given
inalienable human rights based on their
race there's nothing wrong to say you're
you're a you're a mixed race man
but you look like my grandmother looks
whiter than you by the way she was
norwegian but you're a white man i'm a
black man and that's fine it was
interesting you said what was that based
on how they look and how their cultural
values are but not really about who
their ancestors were right it really
it's it's an alludes to that illusion of
what they look like but see because the
ancestor thing once you get there it all
gets murky because what is white if you
go ancestral yeah irish spanish italian
your guy who who's the guy who can't
pick me up no oh oh uh i don't know who
picked you up you've been brian brian
brian yeah my guy brian my guy brian
he's in the front seat of the car he's
driving and he goes uh yeah i'm italian
yeah and i go huh
right but he was like but i joined the
army in the german and i was on a
military base so is he technically a
he's a battalion citizen he's
what i'm saying is that what is white
gets murky black is different i'll tell
you why because black were
full swath brought over
in a transatlantic slave trade and we
lost our indigenous ties but a lot of
the white
immigrants that came to this country
came with those cultural ethnic uh
heritages still intact so
yeah i mean it gets murky when you go to
the ancestral place i would say that if
you look at communities um black blacks
tend to be grouped in certain areas but
that's changing there's gentrification
but there's nothing wrong with saying
that there's race i don't like when p
the right sometimes has this boomerang
effect
where whatever the absurd cultural
narrative is on the left they just go
opposite out of
that happened with the the florida
parental rights and education bill i
started seeing a bunch of conservatives
following
following the narrative of the left the
bill stopped teachers from saying you're
teaching kids about being gay or
whatever which is just absolutely not
true the bill in no way stops teachers
from walking up to a kid and saying
these things and i'm like
the the bill came out
it was a debate and amendments over it
and then the bill that was seeking to be
passed had says nothing to do about
banning the word gay just says you can't
have you know sex ed effectively for
pre-k to third grade
but the democrats ran with this
narrative because it was effective and
then i saw republicans arguing that
narrative and i'm like
it's made up you're not arguing anything
because there's there's nothing there
yeah but they they they walk into these
traps yeah well it's just you know it's
part of its laziness um you know it's
just
intellectual laziness and we built a
society that makes it very hard to be a
deep critical thinker yeah i like
talking about the differences of
genetics of species of people because of
the ancestry like that's fascinating to
me that sickle cell anemia for instance
was showing up more readily in like the
black community in the 60s or something
because of some genetic
difference of genetics of ancestry i
don't know but it's interesting to talk
about with everybody any race color in
person of any language it's interesting
stuff like it's a good thing no too i
think the issue with uh
racism we've talked to a lot of people
about it the reason why it's it's very
obviously rejected by most people
especially amount of times is that you
know if you have a guy from somalia and
a guy from say haiti they might both
have dark skin but be wildly different
in terms of their genetics you know one
guy might be small
might be tall but then if you have laws
or policy based on race
how do you actually determine someone it
sees them as the same person yeah it's
actually racist to do it that way
to see the somali and the haitian person
as both being black or african well
that's exactly it because if if you were
to try and make an argument about like
well the average height or it's like
well
i mean some people from you know are
black and short and some people are
black and tall right and so that's
that's that's the problem with race is
that it really really is superficial
granted i think uh a conversation around
well it's superficial unless 30 million
black babies are are genocided at
planned parenthood over 60 years can you
talk about that well you got a question
that's where race gets real real for me
um so you know my my point to my
conservative republican counterparts is
to say stop saying racism isn't real
because you're giving these neoliberals
an out that's crazy because i thought it
like oh yeah i think of it as a class
issue but i think you're right that
there was some serious racism going on
by the people look at the results well
wasn't that early 30 million black
babies at a planned parenthood there'll
be more babies to die at planned
parenthood in the next two weeks than
died in the ukraine
wow maybe not two weeks let's say a
month two months when does what when
does life begin
it's a tough one i mean
uh at conception that's what i'd say
spiritually i think
if we're talking look
i'm against i'm anti-abortion
but
we we've we've put the law into motion
and there's a trajectory that makes it
hard to
undo without potential unintended
consequences so i don't i don't i'm not
going to say that to 12 weeks
is i don't know what vibe was to me as a
christian i'm just going to say
that maybe the government shouldn't have
the choice but culturally spiritually
and philosophically for me personally to
have a black mother a black grandmother
black sisters
that are we failed as a black community
one but we failed as an american culture
that women would choose abortion so
there's two separate things to go on
there i think one of the two most
important questions
that were asked to uh judge katanji
brown jackson what is a woman
she said she couldn't provide a
definition yeah and that to me is
absolutely absurd she was also asked and
it's not a celebration that she's become
a supreme court justice at that point
right but go ahead the other person if
you don't know what a woman is then why
are we celebrating that a black woman is
supreme court exactly the other question
was about when life begins
we need to have
we we need to to the best of our
abilities try and quantify
uh the world around us so that we can
create effective policy and help protect
people and grant them civil rights if we
can't define a phrase we can't protect
it i agree so in the instance of
abortion and um what is a woman
the reason in my opinion the left won't
give you a definition they'll say i
don't i don't know when life begins
maybe after birth or something they have
no clearly defined point is because that
way they can't do moral wrong right
because if you say life begins a
conception it's a moral wrong at any
point more relativism yeah that's the
that's the linchpin of their whole
ideology now they're saying after birth
and it's just like that way they can
have late term abortions they say what
is omen oh i can't answer that because
then you can have you can you can sort
of massage various institutions in this
country
i think it's it's easily defined
in terms of what they're doing
if a judge can't tell you what a woman
is but then in the same
meet in the same hearing with only a few
minutes say roe v wade is important it
protects a woman's right to terminate
her pregnancy completely absurd you
can't use the word woman in that
sentence with when you can't even define
what it is see but but whatever it
empowers them what you're doing is
you're debunking the logical fallacy and
you do it well i watch you often i'm
like i'm a seeker i appreciate it you're
one of the best in the business that
debunking the logical fallacies i i
really enjoy it but i'm just trying to
understand no no but there's no tell me
the rules there are no rules i know
let's just say what it is they don't
care about the logic right they don't
care because the logic to to
to disavow yourself from the logos which
is a christian idea right the logos to
disavow yourself and detach yourself
from the logos is to give yourself carte
blanche to apply morals and ethics
however you see fit when you see fit
advantageous in most cases for you to be
cruel and predatory and immoral and
let's just draw a hard line
inception add inception if you abort a
child
you conception conception i'm sorry yeah
conception if you abort a child
you take the innocence of a child well
that's that's a grave sin thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there